what up space fam goes in here from
anime up we're back at it again to
discuss the latest craziest developments
in the one piece story there's so much
in this one from luffy versus kaido two
shocking reveals to akaido and big bomb
flashback and more so make sure to stay
tuned for this one if you do enjoy these
one-piece chapter reviews and want to
keep them coming you know what to do
chill the pirating within and smash that
like button with no mercy always
remember smashing that like button is
pirating energy and passing his scared
orochi energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this video subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko supernova
admirals and much more link to that is
in the description and now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all so back to the exciting words of
momo when he brought up zunisha he says
he spoke to zunisha who said he awaits
for orders he's come to fight by momo's
side but momo still doesn't have the
whole picture still it's already a big
deal no pun intended when you look at
the size of zunisha compared to those
tiny ships in the panel again i'm
thinking it might be a good exit
strategy for tired out guys and perhaps
when you shave it takes care of some
enemy ships that are like ant size for
him yamato is excited that momo really
can't speak to it and is convinced more
than ever that just like odin predicted
he's the one meant to lead the world to
its dawn momo for his part speaks of
learning why he cannot die here from
odin's journal but at the same time it
looks like odin tore out the most
crucial page classic one piece here we
gotta have the mystery continue to the
end of course what made odin and roger
laugh at the final island is not there
and the true importance of momo's task
eludes him and he raises some very
interesting concerns he says since odin
wasn't an all-seeing prophet perhaps
under the circumstances of today he
might not even want to open up onno to
the world obviously these are doubts
that will be overcome but nonetheless
context can be important and such
considerations show momo's growth he
says himself he's not as wise as odin
was and when he thinks of the potential
dangers that our people wanna it makes
him want to keep the borders shut and he
asks yamato if that makes him a coward
and obviously the answer is no because
he's thinking of the people and not of
himself but as momo is still working
this out we jump to rhizo who has indeed
won and my ninja boy also made me laugh
harder than anyone else in this chapter
he's pronounced the victor which we
already knew before but i love how he
can't maintain his stoic composure
anymore and he screams out and begins to
say it's hot referring to the fire but
then stops himself realizing he needs to
maintain his ninja cool and says it's
it's not hot not hot at all instead you
can imagine this set in a scream that
reflects his pain which makes it all the
more hilarious ryze also tells
fukurokuju that in this era even shinobi
are free to choose which suggests that
they don't need to blindly follow
horrible and evil rulers loyalty is
important don't get me wrong but when
you're loyal to a terrible evil person
it becomes a fault rather than a virtue
this builds on this arc's criticism of
old outmoded modes of thinking like the
samurai constantly being ready to die
instead of thinking about how they can
win and keep their lives at the same
time our boy jimbei runs into rhizo as
rhizo tells him the preparations are
almost complete we then get to a great
part here where of all people hiri ends
up being the person to actually finish
off orochi now it's not guaranteed that
he's done four but that's the
implication she doesn't need some crazy
power or anything orochi didn't have his
guard up he's panicking and waiting for
his ninja and even calling him good for
nothing after everything he did for
orochi orochi thinks with any luck the
island will soon be history and he
starts getting mad at kumurasaki because
she keeps playing music while everything
is falling apart around them he says
this is life or death and she doesn't
have to be wearing a mask then as if
it's the divine punishment itself the
ceiling caves in and falls down on a
rochi pinning him under it he wonders to
himself why can't he transform he can't
get loose and komurasaki tells him that
he was distracted and didn't notice she
used a sea stone nail to ensure he
wouldn't be able to use his fruit powers
it's like the perfect way to finally
finish him off considering his insanely
endurable mythical fruit the idea of sea
stone nails can also be a game changer
in the future too considering how op
some fruits are however it definitely
makes the most sense to be used on
orochi because orochi is a great example
of someone who sucks without their true
powers so you take them away and you
pretty much have nothing left the best
fighters can kick butt even without
their food powers and then orochi
insults her saying what's going on he
thought she loved him she says loved you
don't be ridiculous there isn't even a
shred of affection for you in my heart
end quote it's a great moment i must say
when you see orochi's angry expression
turned to one of shock and fear he
already says it's almost poetic that
rochi's favorite song is moon princess
because her dad odin loved it too and
that's why she practiced it so hard and
finally orochi realizes that komunasaki
is in fact the daughter of odin he looks
shocked scared and the panel just
showing the mask on hiyori's face and
the smile is chilling truly a
beautifully done sequence of panels by
oda here it's such a perfect way to
finish off orochi who's so scared of
hiri that he has snot coming from his
nose hiri also reveals that she was
wearing the mask because she can't
possibly smile while playing her
father's song for her father's killer
and so the smiling mask is meant to
cover up her true expression and the
effect is even more powerful because oda
doesn't actually show us her true
expression but just lets us imagine it
we then get to izo who did a great job
yeah looks like he's done four and he
tells kiku to live on but he took out a
cp-0 member and that was exactly his
plan from the beginning it's great to
see these guys actually look worried the
masked go player is furious that one of
his own was taken out and laments the
fact that a surviving member of the
whitebeard crew is helping these
upstarts his man tells him to hurry to
get niko robin but his chances are much
worse thanks to our boy ezo then as if
things weren't already complicated
enough for this dude there's a ring he's
like what's up now it's one thing after
another then he hears the big drop and i
quote listen this is a direct order from
the five elders end quote and at this
point the go guy along with us is like
from the five elders really and the five
elders say he must eliminate straw hat
luffy immediately we know that shanks
has met with the five elders so of
course this lends to a theory that
shanks himself could want luffy dead
another detail that can be used in the
shanks is actually evil theory and i
can't blame people for putting two and
two together here i'm still of the
opinion that shanks is our boy and a
solid dude but it is quite the
coincidence that this guy is close
enough to meet with the five elders and
then they order to have luffy eliminated
immediately
crazy stuff let me know your thoughts on
it below what do you make of this order
and the implications of it anyways back
to the chapter even our go player is
like what are you talking about he's in
the middle of fighting kaido you can't
expect me to interfere in that battle
it's impossible and quote the dude just
lost a guy to ezo and now they want him
to interrupt two yonko fighting i
totally get his reaction here the voice
over the phone says we're aware of the
difficulties but the world-class nature
of this battle is what makes this
important don't you get it this order is
a necessary precaution and while this
conversation is going on we see our boy
drake not in good shape but thinking he
won't go down empty-handed i think he
wants to at least try taking down this
lone cp zero agent now how that can work
when he's in this shape i got no idea
but i'm glad to see he's trying i
definitely thought that he was taken out
prematurely the go player appears to be
sweating panting and worried and then we
jump to hamlet helping many escape gotta
love hamlet and his shakespearean slash
giraffe outfit we see frankie worried
about zorro and if he's still kicking
but you know i just can't get worried
here i know zoro will be fine so i don't
think this particular scene had the
intended effect on me but it's showing
us that yeah zoro is very hurt people as
we knew he would be especially after
taking that don't hurt now but hurt way
more later medicine one thing seems
pretty clear though zoro is not
participating in any more fights during
this war we see nami and zeus who's
crying a bit over big mom being taken
down but nami is like bro who matters
more now me or big mom and zeus says you
do nami of course and you love to see it
mark also comments that they can't let
their guards down yet since this island
is still the most dangerous place on the
planet yo even without the yo that would
be a hype statement and one that makes
me question what crazy stuff is
happening off the planet we go back to
kit and law and people are like wow they
really beat big mom people are crying
kid is asking whether they should brace
themselves since kaido is still up there
but law is like no we did our part even
if kaido is the one that comes back down
i have no strength left to put up a
fight and this is what we expect from
one piece luffy's gotta win his fight
because everyone strong push themselves
to their limits to barely win their
fights we see luffy and kaido fighting
which is always exciting this chapter
luffy completely has the advantage kaido
is visibly affected by sensing that big
mom has been beaten he's hilariously
burping as well because of the drinking
luffy thinks about how jaggy and them
really are amazing and it's interesting
to take note of these little details
like that luffy said jaggy and them
rather than mentioning law at least in
this translation is luffy respecting kid
a bit more here it's open to
interpretation but interesting
nonetheless kaido then glimpses the
flashback of a younger and it must be
said more attractive big mom kaido was
only 15 at the time and big mom was
charismatic af she teased him saying
stuff like is that mouth of yours just
for sure don't you know how to speak how
old are you 15 ah to be young so this is
your first time teaming up with rox she
had his back and said if something is
bugging him he could tell her she's
linlin and she's the woman who'll rule
the seas funny enough she was kind of
like a mother figure for him here taking
him under her wing and all their history
and probably her niceness hits him like
a brick wall and he begins to cry this
is weeping drunk kaido and he's like how
could i let this happen we just swore
we'd help each other get the one piece
luffy is shown in the next panel looking
like a beast you see he's got the snake
man form activated and oda did a really
good job with the silhouette here luffy
goes in with punches and with an
especially strong move called gomu gomu
no hydra whenever you're referencing
mythical creatures you know the move is
strong and as the narrator points out
this is luffy's fierce onslaught he
looks to be punching around the
strongest creature in the world who is
clearly not mentally stable right now
luffy goes on to say to him don't talk
to me about your dreams they made the
people of this country starve i'm giving
gear fourth one last go i won't stop
swinging until i have nothing left kaido
was thinking where are these punches
coming from as someone who clearly lacks
the motivation of an up-and-comer these
days he finds it hard to believe that
luffy has so much driving him luffy
screams i'm kicking you out of this
country for good and that's the end of
this chapter it's nice to see luffy even
though he never claims to be a good guy
calling out kaido for mistreating the
people of the country clearly in his
philosophy dreams should not come at the
price of innocent people suffering i
like how even though luffy is sometimes
morally ambiguous as a pirate in a good
way he has a clear personal moral
compass that guides him and you gotta
respect him for it there's no other way
to say it but we are gearing up again
pun unintended for the end of this fight
luffy pretty much said this is his last
go and he's gonna swing until he's done
and hopefully it's enough to take kaido
down the cp-0 agent is probably gonna
have some trouble with drake but he's
definitely someone to watch out for
since if luffy is in zorro's shape after
the fight even if he wins this dude
could show up and just finish his
helpless body off and it's a completely
different story if he interferes before
the fight is even over and thus ruins
luffy's chances i don't know how they're
gonna play this but i really hope luffy
comes out with a decisive victory here
and it definitely looks like it's headed
that way with this latest onslaught of
attacks as always let me know your
thoughts on who is mvp this chapter i
gotta go with my boy luffy here and his
hydra attack our boys really giving it
to the so-called strongest creature in
the world also props to drake and ezo
and hiri so many great moments in this
one and what is going on with the five
elders and their order could shanks
actually be connected to it if he's not
behind it could he know about it and
show up to help so many hype inducing
questions right now but that is it for
this one if you do enjoy the review and
want to keep them coming you know what
to do channel the piraking within and
smash that like button with no mercy
always remember smashing that like
button is pyroking energy and passing is
scared orochi energy so choose wisely if
you haven't make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my one
piece playlist that includes videos on
the yonko supernova admirals and much
more link to that in the description and
until next time see ya space cowboys